In this lesson, we'll talk about editing assets using several of our tools that we have at
our disposal.
Some of the topics we'll be covering is Quixel Mixer, creating blueprints for quick edits,
and the Variant Manager.
When using Quixel Mixer, you want to make sure that your asset is in the center of your
world, and the pivot is in the right spot in the zero-zero point in the grid of your
designated 3D application.
This is very important.
You can do some edits when you bring it into Mixer and also Unreal, but it's better to
have this stuff done ahead of time.
If we look at Mixer up close, you'll see right within our setup, we can choose what we're
going to bring into our scene.
I can have generic assets or have a custom model.
You'll see we have Crunch in here, who is a custom model imported into our scene.
You can also bring in assets from our local library and online.
The hotkeys for that are L for the local library and O for online.
You can bring in those assets and immediately edit them as you work.
This is very convenient and helpful, and allows you to have quick access.
Another thing is when you're adjusting your assets, if you need to, you can also adjust
the scale within our setup options.
You can see here that we can control exactly how our size is going to be.
This works in centimeters, so keep that in mind.
If you're working in centimeters in your designated 3D application, just make sure that is equivalent
to a 6 foot aspect ratio, which is about 183 centimeters in your designated 3D package.
If you're building in that 3D package, just create a cube or a block or some sort of rectangle
object that will represent that 183 centimeters for that 6 foot person, so that you keep everything
within context and then you can put things in place the way that you need.
We can bring in any material that we wish.
We're going to probably leave Crunch for a moment and go to a more simpler one and just
go back to Crunch.
Let's go in here and open our mixes.
We'll look at this alien stone to start out and we'll get back to Crunch in just a minute.
We'll see it load down here off in the very corner, so that it's loading the assets.
This is one complete asset all by itself, no extras, no extra parts, as Crunch does
have different pieces that come in.
In this asset, we have several different layers that we've created.
Up here at the top, you'll see that we have several layers that we can work from.
One of them here is we can add a surface layer if we wish.
This takes us directly into our local library and allows us to grab what we need, but we
can also go to the online library and find anything else that we need.
We see that we're working in all, but we probably more than likely want to work either
with different displacements or the overall just materials in general.
Whenever you're selecting an actual object, Unreal will want to know if you want to edit
that or excuse me, Mixer, and it will give you a prompt for that.
We're going to mainly focus with materials.
Let's go back to the viewport.
You'll see that I have a few already in here.
You'll also see that I created a liquid layer, which you can do here.
You'll see the icon that looks like a drop of water.
I can turn this off and you'll see the liquid layer get removed.
It works similar to what you would see out of a smart material, where it tries to take
into account every aspect of our edges and our normals and changes in shape and tries
to apply the liquid accordingly.
It does a really cool job of doing it.
Again, we can change the color of that.
If I wanted this color to be, I don't know, more of a blue, I can add a blue to it.
You'll see a blue tint.
And we can truly get like that alien landscape we've always dreamt and wanted.
It's really great to be able to edit that.
You'll see the threshold, the radius, and the detail.
All these things can be edited.
And you'll also see if you wanted to add more of some custom masks and so forth, you can
do so.
You also see a thing called an add a layer set.
Now this is new to Unreal and this allows us to be able to paint within particular pieces
or different items that are separate within our model.
If we go back to Krunk, let me make sure I get him here.
Always say his name wrong.
Krunk or Krunk.
It is Krunk.
Krunk.
Sorry, Krunk.
Didn't need to get your name wrong.
I'll say don't say it.
Load him.
You'll see that we have several of these layers already established and created here.
And in with each one, as soon as he pops up here, it's populating right now.
Within each one, we can paint in those pieces and those parts of that model, which makes
it really great to work from.
And you can see as I turn these off and on, you'll see that that ability is there.
And you also can isolate as you're painting.
So if you decide to make a new layer, you can say I don't want these particular target
texture sets to be included in this new layer set that I've made.
So I can turn these off and you can see these are isolated.
This is new to Mixer, which allows us to be able to have more finite control.
It's really great.
You can even create metal masks if you need to in particular areas.
And that's all available for you.
You can also see we can add decals.
So say we just wanted to do a hand smear in this case.
We haven't loaded anything else in our local library, but we can if we go online.
We can find some decals and in those decals, we can add some more things and items to our
stuff.
We can add a lot of different decals that we can choose.
Maybe he has some graffiti that someone's put on his chest.
We can do that too.
So but we'll just say he's part of the Lord of the Rings hand clan.
So we can click on this one here.
And this hand smear is now in place within our scene.
And we can actually paint with it if we need to too.
So if we go to a new paint layer, we can also load different brushes, save different
brushes, but also go and replace them if we have that isolated.
So we can also place that within here.
So there's a lot of control that you can do within these, which is really exceptional.
In this paint layer, if we have another one we just made, we can go in here and paint
the details that we need.
You can increase or decrease using a displacement effect.
You can push up or push down.
This will give you that raised displacement or just set displacement in general so that
when you paint, you can accordingly change that based on our brush shape and jitter size,
all these different things such as angle.
You can control some of these effects as you go through in here.
And if you don't want displacement, simply turn it off.
So now when we paint, it's just raw paint.
We'll undo those because we don't want to affect crunch too much.
We don't want to upset him.
So using Mixer, again, we can turn our eyeball on and off to turn them on, but we can also
choose which type of things we want to paint.
I did mention and show you that you can also load brushes, whether in Photoshop or an existing
brush.
You can turn those decals into painting because right now what we did before, we just loaded
the decal.
But if you wanted to be able to paint the decal, that is available.
And you can also do a masking effect.
You can also control how textures are projected and how they are controlled on an object.
If we go back into Mixer, you'll see that we can actually go to, let's go to one of
these sets that are in here.
And you'll see, we'll open up placement here.
So this is the hand paint that's been done.
And I can control how the placement is on here.
Right now it's just box projection, but I can choose tiling if I wanted to.
And let's actually tweak this out a little bit here.
I didn't undo all the way.
Let's actually undo from our last stuff.
And let's pick, let's mess with scratches.
It'll be a little bit more distinct and we can see that a bit better.
We see some scratches that we see on his knees.
So let's go ahead and rotate and move those scratches, or actually on his arm.
We'll see that move and rotate.
We can choose how that projection is going to be.
We can control tiling.
We can go to free form.
Adds a little bit more edge detail, but you can control again the tiling and the scale.
And we can go back to box projection.
All in here is underneath placement.
You'll see many of these, which are active, we'll be able to have that.
You'll also see that you can add a material ID if you need to.
So you can separate your materials and paint with that particular material on a particular
area if you need that.
You can also add a group if you need to.
So you can make grouping folders.
You'll see right here is a metal mask.
As we click on this, you'll see it's isolated to what is associated with that object.
We can control its opacity if we need to.
That's on the hands distinctly.
And you can add some more details in here if you need to.
So we're not going to add a channel here.
We're not going to get that deep with this, but I want to show you the power of this particular
tool and what you can do.
You'll see the demonstration here within the GIFs within the lecture documentation provided
for you.
I'm showing how you can paint and you can also isolate.
You can say, hey, I want to work with the arms.
I can work with a textured set editor here.
And that actually makes it a lot more easy for you.
So if we go into your layers, you can see the isolation that I talked about.
You can say, hey, I just want to paint on these items in this particular layer set.
And your layer sets up in that corner.
That makes it so you can isolate things a lot better and will help you with your workflow.
If you go into your actual layer sets that you have established, and I'm glad we have
Krunk here with us today, you can actually double click on it and you'll see, or actually
just simply click on it, you'll see what is being isolated for that object.
And that's really helpful.
And again, having that is going to be a very strong benefit to be able to paint on your
objects.
We can now, once we are finished, go ahead and export this out to Bridge.
This is a new feature and extremely helpful.
So if I go back into Mixer, you'll see that options in here so that we can control exactly
what it's going to be.
And we can also customize what we want it to be.
So we can select a category and we can make a brand new category.
And in that Bridge, if we go to our local library and let's go to online and we can
see all the ones that we have.
So once I've exported it, let's go back to the very top.
Let's go to all our categories here.
And let me open up the Bridge real quick.
So in Bridge, we're going to be able to see exactly what we've made custom for our own.
Again, this is all going to be super helpful with your workflows.
So if I bring Bridge over here, we'll see any favorites that we've made.
We have local showing everything that we've downloaded.
We can say purchased collections.
I can also make a new one for myself.
So if I go in here and make a new one, brand new category, do a new category, new robots,
or just call it robots in general, and hit OK.
I can now export this one if I need to.
Export to library.
And it's now going to export this object.
And you'll see the exporting happening here.
It's going to be looking at all the maps, all the accessories, and everything that's
been painted.
And it's going to crunch that down a bit so that we can have this quick and easily brought
out of Bridge into any Unreal scene.
So this is a brand new feature, which allows us to really be able to maintain and control
exactly what we want.
And again, we can categorize new things that we've created, and then we'll take it into
Bridge.
Now, this just takes a little bit of time.
So I'll pause the video for a bit and let that run through because it's kind of squishing
things down.
You'll notice our texture is at 2048.
But when we initially set this guy up, it is set to a 4096 in some cases.
Looks like he might be done.
He may not even have to pause.
So let's go ahead and take a look at that in our library.
So in Bridge, we're going to click on our local library, and we're going to click on
Mixer.
And there he is.
There's Crutch, our robot, with our materials.
And there's a rock that you saw me messing with earlier.
There's that rock right there.
So both of these we've exported.
And now that we've exported them to Bridge, we can send them to Unreal.
It's really that easy.